hello I'm Devin Eric Kapadia and this
morning Adams tres bon ski and myself
for both kernel developers will speak
about asymptotic expansions which are a
third way of computing solutions in the
worm language so we speak about three
new functions asymptotic solve for
algebraic equations a simpler d solve
for differential equations and I saw to
integrate for integrals so together
there are three new super functions and
the Wolfram language
so first I'll be talking about
asymptotic soul then the vendor will
continue and we'll talk about the simple
to integrate that's important dissolve
so asymptotic salt is as many solutions
of algebraic equations
show you the function so that's a
prototype function which is not okay so
the function takes an equation and a
system of equations the value of one
variable or a set of variables and the
point so XY is a single solution point
of the equation of system of equations
we would like to get an asymptotic
expansions of Y in terms of variable X
to the N terms now depending on what
kind of situation we are the those
things will have slightly different
meanings so let let me start with the
simplest situation where we have a non
singular point so the equation is and
also a single variable so in this case
we have an equation with two variables
it's an analytic equation we are at a
point where the function f is analytic
and so by implicit function theorem we
know that near at this point the
solution of Y can be expanded as an
analytic function of X and here we are
getting the regular serious
we
so that we could hunt
I will get a serious in X and there is
exactly one solution also so we can
compare the solution and the numeric
solution you can see that we can also
use the solution to get the numeric
solution so we get the starting point
for it for finding the root as the value
of this asymptotic solution and what
the solutions you see there they're
almost completely equal near near the
point zero zero they start to diverge
around X equal zero point four
now the
more difficult situations so again with
we have two variables we want four
solutions for y in terms of the variable
X but now the function is not singular
so we have a multiple solution and now
what we can hope for is system of with a
serious so can see we have two
dysfunction see if you wish that X goes
to zero we get Y to the seventh power so
it's seventh degree solution and it
splits into two two analytic solutions
one of degree 3 so this is the
denominator 3 we got 3 3 solutions with
powers with denominator 3 & 4 solutions
with powers denominator 4 so we got
several solutions and they are with the
serious but they are still nice serious
they are convergent series are near the
near the point XY equals x 0 y 0 in this
case 0 and we are also able to find the
solutions with real coefficients of so
here is a version
with only three of those solutions have
real coefficients
so this case we can't really say that
there are real solutions they are there
they have real coefficients and they
will be real for positive value of x or
for negative values of effects they will
be complex in general
so here are they the real solution for
example for positive values of X and
again we can see there they are very
close to two like numerically obtain
solutions so they are they're pretty
close to the actual solutions and we can
we can also see that now it's very
useful to have this asymptotic solution
we produce you could find the numeric
solution using them as starting points
and we could find the actual three three
numeric solutions using the starting
points so the next page level
difficulties we have algebraic curves
and dimensions so we have n variables
and minus 1 equations and we get one to
get solution for all variables except
one in terms of the first variable so
here we are looking for solutions for x
and y in terms of the variable Z and
here they are again this was a singular
point we got with a serious but in this
case also the future serious is the
worst we can get we always will get
solutions in with fractional powers
so let me
brought the solutions
here they are we can see there are four
solutions and close to zero they are the
the asymptotic solutions are very close
to the memory solution the one of the
solution actually quite start diverging
from the actual solution quite early so
different solutions can't have different
rate of convergence with the actual
solution so now for possible extension
so this is as much as we have right now
in terms of these functions so the
harder case is now so analytic curves in
n dimensions so this this particular
things that I showed for for n dimension
actually I use the fact that the system
is what's polynomial so for the curve in
2d I could you have arbitrary analytic
function here I actually use the piano
system I use elimination to get a single
equation so what in general it it might
be doable using newton polygons
polytopes polygons is for for 2d case
now more difficult case again so katie
nationals well actually this one is the
smooth surfaces are not difficult so so
if we don't have in n dimensions we can
we can have n minus 5 K equations and we
are good and if the this M is non
singular so the derivative the
determinant of the derivatives not 0 at
the point we can use see a relative
implicit function theorem and get the
actual analytic parameterization of the
surface so that's the nice case now the
simpler cases are more problematic so
the singular surface in an dimension
first person can split into into several
pieces with different dimensions so
that's that's the first difficulty but
even an irreducible piece it doesn't
necessarily have to have the description
in terms of a convergent power series or
freezer seriousiy
it may have peace wise with a serious or
fractional power series that are
convergent in in some combs but in
general it will be his wife solution so
that's the hard case and and also going
to analytic functions instead of
polynomials that's that's also part case
and even a harder case so the next one
is a synthetic expansions at infinity or
at point at which the the system is a
singularity seven so not the solution is
in the system has similarities so that
the function describing this has a
singular pointers with a 0 I 0 so but
that's even harder case and in this case
we are not even getting the power series
we will get actual asymptotic series may
mean we got some functions that
asymptotically tend to put the solution
but but they are not power series so
this is why I thought about solutions of
a algebraic equation of the Vendrell
continuous integration and differential
equations
Thank You Adam
I now go on to the calculus side of
things and I'm going to talk about two
functions new proposed functions
asymptotic integrate which finds a
series expansion for integrals and I
send our D solve which is series
solution of differential equation so
aspera integrate is just like integrate
so you have an expression you want to
integrate over a certain interval but
you also a certain parameter in the
expression or the interval anyone do an
expansion with respect to that parameter
so that's just an extension of integrate
to handle cases where you only have a
series expansion possible so two
examples to show what's happening over
here here is a complete elliptic
integral so that's the complete elliptic
integral part the first two arguments
and your parameter M so you want to
expand with respect to that parameter
and you get back a series from
asymptotic integrate and you can compare
that with integrate so in this
particular case integrate does work and
you get back the elliptic integral of
course you do a series expansion and you
get the same answer so that's one way of
looking at the asymptotic integrate but
the other ways look at n integrate it's
numerical counterpart so here's an
example where you actually have an
exponential decaying function and you
want to do a
okay what
okay so here's the plot of the function
and I want to find a tail end of the
integral over here so what I do is I do
an astronaut to integrate but this time
it used repeat integration by parts so
what you get back is in it is not a
power series looking like an asymptotic
series it is still good but more useful
for numerical work in this case okay so
now compare it and integrate and you get
a as you can see now you get a pretty
good approximation with the asymptotic
solution so that's the idea you have
it's really expansion either use it
directly or do a numerical evaluation
with it
okay now historically the two most
important methods beyond what I just
showed you are the Laplace method and
spatially phase method the Laplace
method is good of course Laplace and
what the Laplace said is that if you
have an exponentially decaying function
like a Gaussian function maybe and it
has a maximum at a certain points in
this case the maximum that one you can
do a series expansion around that point
and get a result for the integral that's
a pretty hard integral actually but you
get back in Nice expression it's a
single term and that single term is
pretty good for giving you an
approximation of the integral but if you
won't go step further on this one term
it also do two terms or three or
whatever like and you can see that early
on you had a slight discrepancy between
the exact width between the
approximation is over here and now that
discrepancy just goes away so just a
single term in the expansion I think
next term this is a good and that's the
magic of asymptotic say I I'm not
working with myself one and this amazed
how nicely it works okay so that's
Laplace and then what Stokes said is
okay let's do the same thing for
oscillatory functions
like you know sines and cosines so
here's an oscillatory function and
that's the real part what we notice is
that all the action is around the
maximum at PI over 2 they're kind of
right so what you do is you do an
expansion around there the same trick
with what you do with Laplace and lo and
behold in just a minute
I'll be able to show you that you get
back a an approximation now that
approximation is pretty good it's also a
tree so it's not so easy but you do get
back and to go beyond that what you do
is you transform the Laplace case the
good old trick of converting a complex
integral into a real integral and you
get back a nice on sir
so that's integrating in a few minutes
and I now going to ask Modi saw which is
the other function which I've been
working on and this is a kind of
complete solver for all kinds of
solutions ordinary points regular
singular points regressing the point
knowledge Rodi Rodi everything is
already more or less working so some
examples but first of all what's the
function very simple function you have a
differential equation you have a
dependent variable X and you won't find
this to be expansion people written
these for a long time on their own this
is now our own implementation ok so
ordinary points so now here you have no
particular problem in the equation there
are no singularities in the coefficients
at 0 so you get back in Nice Taylor
expansion and that data expansion is
easy to plot you get back lots of
approximations that's a textbook example
of solutions at an ordinary point ok so
next I go on to regular singular points
and now things get a bit harder because
what you have is a singularity in the
coefficients but it's pretty mild we
have an x Square and the leading
coefficient I divide through by it you
don't get a match single arity and it's
a situation computer for being a city
solution and we give back the answer but
now you don't have a paucity to have it
square root of x over here and a 1 over
X over there that's the pro-business
method from college calculus so only
point done regular point single points
done how about a regular well for that I
thought I'd choose the heir equation
which Adam mentioned expensive infinity
so now this equation is well known to
have an irregular singular point at
infinity so if you do X equal 1 over T
then you get back a an integral
similarity at 0 ok so here's the answer
for the expansion there are two parts
each part is an exponential and a kind
of special series and what the
exponential is it's a factor which will
reduce the singularity down to a regular
case that's how we think of the
exponential factor ok so now you do a
comparison with the airy function you
see with exactly the same answers for
each component over there
one other area IR the API and if you
plot them then because they're infinity
initially the expansion doesn't match
but at infinity each expansion each
approximation clings on to the correct
function so it's pretty remarkable how
dicey answers are when you start working
with them and of course this was
blindingly fast it's a general algorithm
for holonomic Odie's or irregular single
points follow me cody's or you can do
order 7/10 what we like it always
blindly fast
not yet I mean in a sense that's what
you're doing by the way already doing
that this all does that already because
I give you a finite interval right and
on that interval we do a delay equation
since version 10 so what you get back is
essentially a positive solution because
we're kind of a silly solution because
we kind of bring it step by step is that
what you mean by like that yeah right
and we have done that since version 10
indie solve but yeah not not yet but
it's that's a great suggestion okay
the order now is finish up the ori case
then P Dirac cetera but sure that that's
definitely oh yes oh yeah yeah oh sure
okay that's only for the regular case
analytic the integral kiss is to be
worked on but yes likely possible so you
mean just general coefficients right not
polynomial right oh right right
I guess that should work I haven't tried
okay so probably should but at the
moment we're looking infinity and making
transformation specifically so I don't
think we're doing it less another goods
nation I look into that the question is
what happens if you're if you want to
get negative infinity instead of
positive infinity
yes so so for the integrate side I've
done it I have not looked into it for be
solved by somebody so but either so so
there are two goods relation debate
equations from scan and negative
infinity okay
and finally tech support is pretty good
about asking me questions when people
send them so here's an example of a
nonlinear D story is that maple can
solve it return the four line solution
Mathematica takes a long time to put
politely and they send it to me
and what I do nowadays then I get exams
this type I just do it to my new
favorite function and you see I've set
the number of terms to 32 but what you
get back is in fact a finishes a
quadratic polynomial so that is an exact
solution so maple is wrong mathematic is
wrong the solution is a polynomial
solution and we found it now okay so
well not there not wrong but what we're
doing is not very useful so okay so I
check the solution is correct and I have
found an exact solution using
approximate method I have an exam from
Kip Thorne the Nobel Prize winner which
is similar maybe get back the right
answer with the asymptotic method but
not such a good answer with okay so so
now I go into perturbation expansion
that's the other side of the story well
you have a perturbation parameter in the
problem in addition to the independent
dependent variables so here's an example
the Duffing equation it's an oscillator
so you expect a periodic solution and
around 1890 or so Paul Kinlan state
worked out the so called punker in state
expansion for these things where you get
back periodic things in your
perturbation expansion what is a simple
it is it's just got two terms in it a
cosine term and scientific over and then
epsilon times something else but that is
good enough to capture the solution to a
pretty good extent because if I now
compare to the exact solution from B
solve which took a lot of work to get
done
it's got Jacobian elliptic functions in
it that's a mess and so gives you
roughly the same okay they are so two
terms of perturbation is good enough to
match your elliptic function solution
okay
so my final example now best with
boundary layers so roughly speaking a
boundary layer theory is what you do in
fluid dynamics where Lubich pen tool is
19:4 I wrote a paper on he said that if
you have a viscous fluid and you've got
let's say a wing or something that to it
then all the action takes place in a
small thin boundary layer around that
body so you have a separation of the
fluid into an inner layer and an outer
layer and what you want to do is you
want to match those two expansions and
get a nice solution so around 90 and 40
Godfrey Rix came up with a very simple
example that's over here so the problem
is you have and the parameter epsilon
over here we set epsilon to 0 things go
wrong so that's a singular perturbation
problem fortunately we have wkv method
from quantum theory which gives you a
really nice solution in this case a
linear approximation sorry first time
proximation you plot it actually find
table values compared with V solve or do
you solve value in this case you get
back
almost the same solution numerically but
look at the complexity of the
proclamation was the exact and in fact
we plot them both they look almost
identical and they look almost identical
is because I added the plus point zero
point zero one over there if I had not
done that be exactly match so it is a
single term in the perturbation series
we have got so much power of computation
so I think this is a wonderful area of
development it's still working on it so
basically I think that asymptotic
expansions are powerful alternative to
symbolic and numeric methods at the
moment we're talking about algebraic and
differential equations and integrals
well keep in mind wait we got D solve
solve integrate three big functions and
now we're going to velop a few more case
so we would like to go on doing this and
also improve series another thank you
very much